hmm
ah
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
um
[Music]
mm-hmm
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone
hi i am lucy james here from gamespot um
i'm going to be doing camera off stream
today because i figured you know you're
just going to be wanting to see the game
and me being in a way is not an ideal
way of seeing it so hi everyone welcome
in
we are gonna be playing the opening
couple of hours of horizon forbidden
west the latest from gorilla games uh
playstation four and five exclusive
you'll notice that i'm starting
from this screen
oh
wait one second that's why
try that now if i've got double voice if
i'm a robot that should work
um
the reason i'm starting from this screen
is because the game kind of boots you
into like a cutscene it's kind of the
um
little recap that it does
um
echo should be fixed now but let me know
if it's not um
it
boots you into this cutscene which is
basically like a little bit of a recap
of horizon
zero dawn
which
came out five years ago
five years ago it doesn't feel like it
but it really did and honestly if you
haven't played it recently
i would really recommend watching a
fuller recap because horizon forbidden
west is set like six months after
and
it it kind of
it hopes that you remember a lot of it
um so i am gonna be quiet obviously
throughout cut scenes
um
but yeah that's just my my warning
is to watch watch some kind of recap we
i mean to pimp the merge we've got a
great one here on gamespot
um
oh here we go the nice playstation uh
studios logo
very marvel
um
so we'll just get we'll get into it and
if you can hear that noise in the
background that's my cat so
she's really going to town on the
scratching post
as i'm playing if you have any questions
uh chuck them in the chat we're gonna
keep it as spoiler free as possible just
focusing on the early game so let me
know lifetime
spent in the pursuit of knowledge
one question consumed
how did our world come to be
the old ones perished a thousand years
ago
triggering the extinction
of all life
she
showed me how it was reborn
a little outcast girl
ignorant of her own importance
through her
i learned that life was only saved
through a technological miracle
zero dawn
a terraforming system composed of nine
subordinate functions
each
playing its part to reshape earth from a
barren rock
to a lush landscape
tended and protected
and with her
i learned the deepest secret of them
the
all
of her birth
that she is a clone of elizabeth
zero dawn's creator
born to prevent a new extinction
given sentence by a mysterious signal of
unknown origin
and with a little help from me
she prevailed in a great battle at the
city of meridian
becoming a champion for all humankind
[Music]
but as useful as she has been
now
i must leave her behind
for as she strives to put right what
hindi sundered
i have made a new discovery
one that heralds both destruction
and opportunity
so there we have it so it's not exactly
like an in-depth
um it's more of a sort of casual
overview um of what happened in the
first game and kind of the setup for
this one i'm going to change a couple of
things in here or at least show you the
menus before we kick off so i'm gonna
make sure that
subtitles are turned on
uh okay motion blur
okay so in in terms of gameplay wise
high fidelity to lower frame rate so we
can either play graphics in performance
mode or um in resolution mode i'm going
to say let's play in resolution mode so
you get a look at how
the game um
looks in terms of uh you know all of its
beauty at the at least at the beginning
we can change it to performance mode in
a bit if we want to
subtitles aren't on
oh one thing that i really want to do is
where is it
weirdly
they did change some of these settings
uh in between like the um
when we got the game at the beginning um
like we've had it for a couple weeks and
there were some
settings in here that they seem to have
changed like you could actually
apparently turn a line uh she talks a
lot you'll discover that in a bit um
ayla talks a lot and uh you could turn
that off the the one setting i'm looking
for here is quick swap and i can't
remember where it is uh wake up and
quick swap this is really useful and for
some reason it's turned off by default
um but basically when you have it
enabled you can tap l1 to quickly swap
back to the previous weapon that you had
instead of like holding down the weapon
wheel and i have no idea why this is
turned off
at a default um but anyway yeah i can
only stream at uh 1080p because of the
comcast gods
but i am streaming at uh
60 frames
let's kick off
let's do normal
um and so yeah and another kind of
difference here is that you can play in
explore or guided mode which is actually
very similar to if you've played
assassin's creed one of the later ones
explorer mode
a little bit more minimal when it comes
to stuff on the hud
um and guided mode is very much like
chucking everything in the wall i would
still argue that even in explorer mode
it is quite a busy hud and you'll see
what i mean uh maybe that's just regards
to the fighting but let's get let's get
going
autosaves
always good
so
[Music]
i'm running out of time elizabeth
the land is dying
people are suffering
soon
i'll starve
all because of a terraforming system
that's spiraling out of control
and only i
can fix it
only i have your genetic code
it won't be long before we hit the point
of no return
and then
extinction
i've been searching for months for what
i need
a backup of gaia the aiu designed to
control the system
but every time i think i have a lead
that comes to nothing
and every night i have the same dream
i'm walking under a brilliant night sky
through a field of flowers
and when i arrive at the center
i see you elizabeth
waiting for me
even though you've been
dead for a thousand years
you're the closest person i've ever had
to a mother
[Music]
and for a moment
i feel whole
[Music]
but it never lasts
i'm always left alone
[Music]
this world is your legacy elizabeth
i won't let it slip away
[Music]
the valley below is my only remaining
lead
my last hope to find the backup
i'll do whatever it takes to get it
i promise
if it is an a-lord the savior of
meridian
anointed of the nora you know i hate
being called that stuff well consider it
a punishment for running out on us the
very same night we beat hades
i grew up an outcast remember i'm not
much for parties
yeah
that one was in your honor
just saying
so
what are we doing
must be urgent since you left so fast
delving into ancient ruins
or maybe it has something to do with the
blight
both
actually but um
i shouldn't oh no
i've been tracking you a long way it's
okay after everything you've done to
help the nora and my family i swore an
oath to help you no matter what
you're stuck with me now
like bark on wood
[Music]
okay
but
if you're going to come with me
you'll need to be able to see what i see
a focus
never thought i'd get your second sight
i'll give you another one later and show
you how to back up your data
data
information
on the device we've got a lot to cover
um i'll have to explain everything as we
go
[Music]
you see like this all the time
since i was a little girl
come on
shall we
all right i got a couple of scrapes on
the way here
we should find some medicinal plants
stock up
so it's time for your first lesson with
the focus
sounds good
let's get started
all right so now we're in
um these plants don't look like the ones
in the sacred lands
the focus helps you see the ones we need
so funnily enough i actually remapped
these buttons uh on my playthrough i
swapped healing and i swapped my focus
um so if i accidentally heal myself it's
because i think i'm using my focus but i
will i can't bother to change it right
now
um
you might want to grab more of these
plants along the way
yeah little tutorial section to get you
to really um pick up some plants they
don't like
i don't know
you kind of go through them quickly and
alloy has a stash so i would definitely
say that it's in your best
interest to just pick him up as much as
you can one of my big gripes with the
game i've got to say is that like she
will stop to pick stuff up rather than
um like just walk over and pick it up
which can be pretty annoying especially
because of the amount of crafting that
you have to
this do spreads fast
six months ago the land was fine
now it's everywhere
those ruins that's where we need to go
i see a few ways down go down this way
absolutely always going to go down
a zip line
it's an ai
it's um
it's hard to explain
think of it like
a set of instructions that can fix the
world
so you see the blight here actually if
you run over it it does ding your health
you don't
come across it that much i would say
it's not like an annoying thing that you
keep coming across oh here we go
some boys
looks like they left a carcass behind
let's head down and check it out
oh yeah so my hud is said to be like off
um but if i wanted to get everything all
at once i just swipe up on the touchpad
it's nice i much prefer it that way it's
not as cluttered
um
it just it just looks a bit nicer
a lot of arrows in that machine
okay let's grab some ridgewood
this is the ps5 version vincent
someone took down this machine recently
who else would come here
i don't know i better craft some mirrors
of our own
there might be trouble with that
good thing we already picked up some
ridgewood
damn right
there's a ladder
but i am just going to keep getting rid
of
it
i wish like even in even in the kind of
foraging uh like hunter trap
a trap kind of uh
skill tree there isn't a way
you you can you can unlock skills that
mean that you get more resources
whenever you pick stuff up but you can't
like just walk over stuff i know i know
it seems like such a little thing but
honestly like 40 hours into this game
you will be mad every time you have to
pick up something and like stop
um
and and kind of stop how does it feel at
30 i
honestly it feels great like it looks
great i'll swap the frame rate in a bit
like i am streaming at 16.
um
we need to find a way in
so um
what happened after i
left maria
well there was a fuss when people
realized you were gone
but then some of us figured you only
would have left if it were for something
important
you're right about that
and also the benefit of having played
this game before is that i can hopefully
remember the way in here we go
vincent uh her regarding her hair
actually it was a little bugged um in
the the preview
section um and this is a big fix
get to the grass
oh mr dreadful they do explain the beard
don't worry about it
okay
okay see how parts of it are glowing
those are its weak spots got it
it's i
it's a weak spot
[Music]
clean
clean
another one's coming
find anything good
a few supplies oh
less clean
oh
[Music]
yeah
kind of the focus is really eloy's uh
personality uh you'll find especially in
the early hours
or if you remember the first game
what did everyone else
my mother do the rest of the nora home
all right
you said you've had a focus since you
were a child right
yeah
i found my first one when i fell into a
ruin
got the others from an old cache not
long ago
it's good to have extras
through here
welcome to the far zenith launch
facility
i know they made some tech trades with
zero dawn but
why would they have a backup of gaia
please register with reception for the
tour
i guess they want us to check in with
them
please hold for identiscan
access denied
please wait here for personnel to assist
you dr sobek
okay
i guess they weren't on great terms with
elizabeth
well
let's find a way in
all right
i'm sorry i was just checking a setting
please hold for identity
denied
credentials um i will join to take a
look at the skill tree
um
so i don't have any skills just yet that
i can grab but like
uh horizon zero dawn had four skill
trees and forbidden west has six
um
and honestly like don't be afraid of
getting um
don't be afraid of like thinking that
you won't be able to tap into all these
because every time you level up or every
time you complete a piece of side
content you get two
um
skill tree uh it gets two skill points
so
a lot of the early skills um you can
quickly buy and invest in and like a lot
of them are
passives and also a lot of them are
obviously active skills but the cool
ones
um are these valor surges so
if you kind of buy these surrounding
skills um which are all very useful like
passive boost to range here um quiet
movement
this one um whereas it's silent strike
there is a silent strike
uh skill that i absolutely recommend you
get
um which basically means that if you do
a silent strike it gives you health back
um but anyway if you if you buy these
surrounding skills you unlock this
center one and you can this is basically
like your ultimate
which means that uh in the middle of
battle
you can activate this and you can be
super super uh you just get a really
cool ultimate ability for a little bit
so this one is my favorite this is the
one that i have currently equipped which
is stealth stalker comes in three
different levels um
it basically means that like you can go
invisible you don't go completely
invisible so like if you are right in
front of an enemy they will still see
you but if you are you know just kind of
out
if you kind of break line of sight and
then go invisible they have no idea
where you are and if you
um
boost if you like continue to invest in
this
you get like a major damage boost if
you're in this mode and if you keep
killing people while you're invisible
you can prolong how long you're
invisible for it's really really cool um
and then you have other ones where it's
like um
so you have six skill trees and each of
them have a couple of vala surges um
warriors probably a good one to invest
in if you like it doing a lot of melee
combat
trapper is my personal favorite trapper
hunter and infiltrator my probably the
ones that i've invested the most in
um just because uh we'll see in a bit
but traps are
pretty overpowered in this game
um
in a good way um
hunter obviously if you want to be uh
you know use bows a lot um survive is
very good because you get like
a bunch of uh benefits from using um
uh you get a bunch of benefits from
using uh
just like um
jesus that guy's bad luck
uh by using medicinal berries and
potions etc potions i will say that i i
do not use a lot of at all i just heal
through stuff
i should be able to pry this open
but anyway we'll we'll take a look at
the um
at those in a little bit when we
actually get some points
i did not review the game um i've just
been playing pre-release and helping out
on features um
earlier
our review was done by phil hornshow and
he gave it an 8 out of 10.
you can read it on gamespot you can
watch the video review that max cut on
the youtube what's that stench
champ
camp
find out
they must have come here to delve for
scrap
acid
that explains the smell
it looks like something big came in from
above
uh gand in the gray definitely need
potions for the ultra hard run yeah i i
think on normal you just really don't
need to get the rubble in that gap
um
whatever came through here brought this
down as it went out
if i can dislodge some of the debris
we might be able to squeeze through
maybe i can find something to help in
the camp
over here
i think i got something
it's some kind of osurum prototype i
think
this hook looks like it can latch onto
things
and the scare pulls it back
it looks broken but maybe we can repair
it hook it to the debris
and pull it out
that could work
the focus can help us search the camp
and identify anything we can use to fix
the tool
my focus picked up a couple of things to
check out
part of the machine
could help fix the gears
unless it's one's okay
machine cable
stronger than rope all right i think i
have what i need to repair the tool
or maybe even make something better
you could use this workbench so this is
another new thing for the game
workbench um you can use it to craft
like you kind of get these um special
pieces of gear that you use throughout
your journey um but also a really
cool thing is that later on if you um
you can obviously make
um like craft uh weapons and ammo but if
you craft them at the workbench you um
you don't use as many resources so it's
very useful um it's also where you
upgrade stuff later on uh
pull caster
now to test it on the debris
uh we're playing on ps5
it's spoiler free because it's the
beginning of the game a spoiler would be
if i told you how it ended
which
you know i would never
[Music]
oh yeah it's like weird to line up the
pull caster
that works better than i thought
how big is the map i don't think i can't
see it right now but the map is is big
um i'll show it to you when we get out
of here
what's this
whoa good morning
i'm osvald
and it is my pleasure to introduce you
to
far zenith
forget what you think you know about us
our truth is simple
we say reach for the stars even if you
have to cross 8.6 light years of space
to get there
please proceed into the auditorium where
we'll unveil our plans
wonder what's in this auditory
i guess we'll find out it plays best on
series x oh my god
uh
i thought i thought it was a grapple
point but i guess not
i might be able to get up there so it is
a grapple point but it's one of those
things where the game makes you
scan it before you can use it wow
that works
um i haven't
so you suck 40 into it is that
everything
don't worry um you can finish it in like
30 odd hours i would say but there's a
lot of side content so it's like it
depends on how much you want to invest
in it really
um i need to help my guy get up
where is the is there a ladder
oh i didn't sprint
i didn't sprint even though the game
told me to sprint damn it all right it's
like
i guess i don't know if you can hear but
like there's a lot of the sound is
coming out of my dual sense controller
and not like i don't know if it's coming
out of the game itself
oh my god i was looking at chat it's
like how long is the main campaign like
i said it depends on how much you put
into it really i think you could
probably get it done in like 25-30 hours
but there's so much side stuff
and like because you don't want to be
under leveled for things like the final
boss
um
it's yeah i don't know i think 30 to 40
hours
okay sprint this time
i swear there's a ladder around here
somewhere i throw my friend in
there it is
okay i gotta drop the ladder for laurel
coffee or tea i'm having a cup of coffee
right now because it is 10 30 in the
morning
sometimes these doors will be right
trigger to open and sometimes they'll be
triangle it's a fun little guess to see
which one they will decide
homo sapiens
us
we have always pushed the boundary as
explorers pioneers trailblazers
and now far zenith is taking the next
leap into the future
that's why we're proud to have
resurrected the odyssey
when our government's abandoned in orbit
far zenith will actualize in less than a
decade
but that's only the beginning
when the ship is complete we will send
the odyssey and her crew
where no one's gone before
[Music]
the serious system
there will create humanity's first
off-world colony
the odyssey may take 300 years to reach
it
but when we look up at the night sky
we'll know they're on their way
and in the words of our founder the late
peter shin boom bay
the trees
the old ones could fly through the sky
between the stars
well
yes
sort of
that ship
the odyssey it
never made it to the other star
something went wrong and it blew up
is that why elizabeth gave them a backup
of gaia
for their colony
error
public presentation file corrupted
member recruitment file available do you
wish to reactivate yeah
reactivate
let's see what else they had to say
[Music]
we all know the projections
economic instability
new bio contagions
rampant ais
how long before another catastrophe
creates unacceptable risk for the
world's elite
we here at farzenith believe
escape the inevitable
and so we reach for the stars
now you've seen what we're building here
infrastructure to support the odyssey's
construction
a state-of-the-art data center to
facilitate rapid technological
advancements
and you've seen how we're managing
public perception
so invest
and join us
claim your birth on the odyssey preserve
your way of life beyond the concerns of
earth
well they were right about the world
ending i just didn't know how
yet
so everything they said back there about
the next step for humanity
it was all a lie
these people only cared about saving
their own skin
yeah well
didn't work out for them in the end
that oldsvault guy mentioned a data
center
there
the backup this should be stored in
there
won't be able to swim across
i guess we'll have to find a way around
come on
this hologram is giving mass effect to
adult vibes
yeah there's a lot of that there's a lot
of uh
they've kind of done away with the audio
logs um if you remember like in the
first game every time you would scan
something with your focus there would be
like a little audio log and they are
there but they don't play automatically
you have to like
go into your menu
see down there got some blight and if
you missed it in the beginning if this
stuff is like kind of everywhere but not
like bad enough but like if you go on it
see it dings my health um
up here
careful i don't want those things to
call in some friends from underground
you take the left one i'll do with the
one on the right
okay
all right time for some stealth
i need to sneak up on it to take it out
with my spear
already
oh yeah this is the uh learn where it
walks
looks like this guy just goes in a
circle
yeah this is running on ps5 uh currently
in am i infidelity mode yeah i'm not in
performance mode
tap to wield the rock
there is there is they're quite lenient
on how far away you can be to do a
silent strike by the way i found it very
very useful
um especially because there's like a
bunch of thoughts and stuff you go to
later on and it's like
it's very it's quite lenient
um which is pretty good
i can't jump up there huh all right
i will say eloy can climb a lot more
things than she could in the first game
um
i feel like that's something they really
listen to like especially because it
came out the same time as um
uh breath of the wild and like you could
climb on everything in that game but in
horizon you like really couldn't um
but in this one it's way more lenient
than what you can and can't climb on um
which is great
is he coming yeah he comes around here
just right then
i've got your back
don't need to have my back mate this is
a tutorial
and in terms of the the ui um i've seen
a question about that it's like
it's i have it on dynamic right now so
if i swipe up on my um touchpad then
that's how it comes up and i get like my
quest objectives and uh quest markers
and stuff
um
and then he is over there
oh is he looking for his friend who i've
just killed
i don't feel good about that
see what i mean about silent story like
i was far away there um but it's pretty
it's lenient
um and i think there's only two of them
in here oh no there must be another one
because it's telling me that i have not
finished
i want to say
see up here
oh he's down there
hello mate
no i thought i could cheese him
but i could not
oh where's that
okay i've been meaning to mention
i noticed you have a
new look these days
yeah i know
didn't have a lot of time to shave when
i was trying to catch up to you
don't worry it's not permanent
good
sorry my whiskers offend
you looks like this little guy got
caught up in the blight
um i think it does have the option to
turn off the ui completely we'll take a
quick look
um
it's in visual
or zoom controls
hard visibility yes mines mine's on
dynamic
custom and then in here yeah you can
turn a bunch of stuff off
um but i like your mang on dynamic
must have used explosives against the
machines give me some shots
all right
looks like there was a barricade here
machines must have broken through
i mean i wouldn't say the decima engine
is an old one it's the one that uh death
stranding used as well i
i think it's just as pretty as unreal
engine 5
um
i guess that also didn't have a chance
but yeah it's like more specifically
made for more tailored for pc and
playstation
careful traps ahead
yeah no problem massive g if anyone else
has any questions or stuff they want me
to check that's not going to be too
spoilery let me know happy to do so if
not i'm just going to play through the
story
you wanna do the 60 frames version all
right let me do that
uh
i'm going in performance mode everyone
and if you can hear my cat in the
background she's going wild
all right so now we're in 60. i haven't
actually played this any of the game in
60 frames i've been playing it in 30 so
while we're here maybe we can make some
traps of our own
yeah boy it's time for traps
good idea
let's go
give me some stuff
oh i don't have the right supplies to
craft a trap
okay and it looks like the awesome shot
off some machine parts
i might be able to scrounge up enough
materials from them
i can use this
no i'm looking at twitch chat too so if
you have questions there feel free
okay
i should have what i need to craft a
trap
there
explosive trap made
if anything walks into one of those
they won't know what hit it
over here
i think i see your way up
oh maybe not
come on
we could place one of those traps you
made in its path
did it see me god damn it
no it didn't
oh yeah see traps are
the one thing is is like the one thing i
would recommend is definitely
in the the menus uh investing in skills
that let you lay more of them
um
because at the beginning of the game at
least you can only really lay
a couple and it's you know
if you want to
properly
uh
you know
lay a bunch of them it's it's kind of it
sucks a little bit because you have to
just wait until a
machine
um
falls on it
[Music]
see what i mean so that took that one
out completely
um
and then he's gonna go get the other one
oh he's actually coming over here
playing on ps5
uh we're playing in the the 60 frames uh
performance mode
go on
go back to your path
uh so max has been saying that like you
know the trip wire
uh the tripwire is actually like a
little nerfed compared to how it was
in the first game because it it
definitely feels a little
more finicky to lay it like it's really
if you don't put it on a flat surface
and you can't really stretch it out as
far
um and so they break which is a little
bit frustrating
which is why i kind of prefer traps like
i just lay traps
catch the machine's attention and then
they run towards me and just like run
over it um which is what i'll do here so
hang on because this guy's just really
not getting the point come on
[Music]
oh did that not even get him
did he set off my own trap did val set
off my trap
get him in the ass
oh
there we go and then a knock down
j nichols i'm you know what it is very
much like the first game in a lot of
ways um i would say that it feels
a little bit more refined
um
just like i don't know a little bit more
sure of itself
it looks nicer for sure um they've made
like a lot of cool um additions to it so
like you get a kind of little glidery
type thing um
there's a lot of
climbing puzzles which i really enjoy it
feels like there are more of them the
story also feels
it's a little uneven i'll give it that
but there's a point in it where it kind
of reminds me a little bit of mass
effect 2 there's like this bass that you
get and you know characters are there
and you kind of um you hang out with
them and form relationships with them
um
so i don't know it feels overall it
feels a bit stronger my biggest gripe
with the game and it's not really
present at this point but you definitely
will notice it later is that a loy when
she's out by herself just talks to
herself all the time
and because she has a pack um like when
stuff is when her when her pack is full
she sends stuff to her stash and she
comments on it
every single time and it's
great it genuinely does which is like
not the best i wish you could turn that
down
see what i mean so like
that would ordinarily be an audio log um
and now it's just something that you
know
you
collect it doesn't explain how they got
it back up
keep an eye out for more data
looks like we've got to climb up
huh
a lot of glyphs
i'll talk just a way to study later
yeah so it's really useful that you can
just
ping the environment i know this wasn't
the first game club go back
uh
ping stuff and just use it to climb
and it and like you can already see
there are way more options than in the
first game
definitely wants you to scramble about a
bit more well it is a thousand years old
looks like some kind of meeting room
that door on the other side
zero dawn terraforming system
the brainchild of dr elizabeth sobek
empowered by nine subordinate functions
gaia the core of the system
is capable of advanced planetary
engineering
an obvious advantage to our space
colonization efforts
operation phase one establish an asset
within project zero dawn status complete
phase two the asset will secretly be
cast a complete copy of gaia and her
subordinate functions to this facility's
data center if all goes well zero dawn
staff will remain completely unaware of
the transmission risks discovery of this
operation could result in zero dawn
withholding the already negotiated
apollo database
special care must be taken not to alert
travis state the expert hacker in charge
of haiti's protocol
in addition
extreme caution must be exercised in
regards to dr sobek herself
as one of the world's preeminent
technologists she may have instituted
unforeseen security measures
a complete assessment is attached this
concludes the executive summary
i thought elizabeth sent the back up
here
but she didn't
far zenith stole gaia
eloy
why does that woman look like you
um
it's okay bro we
look alike because
we're the exact same
genetically identical but she was one of
the old ones
how can you be her
because i wasn't born
i was
made
by a machine
it's
why i'm motherless why i
was cast out as an infant
i don't understand
what kind of machine can make a person
remember when i said the backup is like
a set of instructions it's
more than that
it's called gaia
and for a long time she cared for the
world until she had to
destroy herself
so she made
me
to bring her back
i'm the only one who can
and this place
is my last home
you once said the goddess spoke to you
when you went into all mother mountain
was that this
gaia
yes but
she's not the goddess laurel
there isn't one how can you be sure
it sounds like she anointed you with a
sacred task
i've had a lot of time to figure this
out and you will too
with the focus but for now
the reports said they were going to
store the stolen copy of gaia in the
data center
so that's where we have to go
okay
all right
plot plot
um
so
i saw a couple questions in the chat
like people saying is it going to come
to pc there is no official word just yet
however
a lot of first party
uh playstation stuff is coming to pc the
original horizon came to pc so i would
not
i don't think it's outside the realm of
possibility
thanks merle
um someone else commented that the slide
looks annoying honestly the slide is
really fun
i uh hang on
it looks great it's really fun and uh
max uh on our team
he'll know from like breath of the wild
videos like he has
uh he
basically speed runs and and there's a
um
a breath of the wild expert
he realized that if you run slide and
then dodge you are invincible pretty
much for all of that and so it's really
useful when you are in a fight um just
fyi so if you want to see more combat
tips like that max has put up a video
should be up on the channel right now
down here
yep
i think we're almost back outside
good
ah there it is
oh
my boat
oh we're nowhere near the forbidden west
by the way the forbidden west we don't
even get there for a good couple hours i
don't think we're still on the kind of
like east side
of the map
okay
yeah
all those places i've been these last
few months
there were supposed to be more backups
about a thousand years ago a guy named
ted pharaoh urged them all
would be part of parliament
because i
feel like there's a
boss fight coming up pretty soon
so the sound
sounding game isn't that good it might
be because
some of it is also coming through my
controller
um
it uses the dual sensors uh like little
speaker thing so i'm playing on ps5
uh
but yeah with regard to a pc port
you can tell uh larry i think you're
totally right i don't think it's gonna
be any time soon
if it does ever come
and like i don't know sony has said in
the past like we they definitely want to
put more stuff on on pc but like
for a big first party title like horizon
i wouldn't i don't think it's going to
be very soon
all right where are you coming in he's
coming in over here all right
i'm just gonna blow this guy up traps
are so much fun
i almost feel bad you know
i don't feel that bad
look
at his
i don't know where's he gone
and yeah it's gonna look better when you
actually play it because we're dealing
with youtube and twitch compression
i didn't realize there was one of these
around
i'm just grabbing all this stuff because
it will be very useful
come on
there's there's way more traps there's
like acid purge water
um there's like electric ones there's
that one that i've been using the the
kind of blast trap
um
so tell me something it's really useful
especially if you like you don't have
the
specific arrow um
kind of corresponds to an enemy's weak
point uh it's very very useful to have
traps is she ever pleased i personally
think they're a little bit too
overpowered i got really stuck on a boss
fight and it was like
it killed them in two traps like i
didn't even have to
hit them with an arrow it was ridiculous
so i think they're a little bit
overpowered right now but at the same
time i'm not mad about it
three of those things
and if they slaughtered all those
awesome we'll never get through to the
data center
there's no way to slip past them
they're too tough to fight head-on
we could find a settlement
convince some hunters to help us that
would take weeks and we don't have that
kind of time
maybe all we need is that shuttle to
fall
that
thing how
we'll figure it out just wait here
hey
trust me
and there she goes
just need to get over to the shuttle to
figure out how to make it fall
yeah this isn't hardest difficulty this
wouldn't just plain on normal
if i can make it to that tower
i should be able to find a way across to
the shuttle
[Music]
i also wish that like you could just
take everything when you kill some when
you kill a thing you know instead of
like if i hold triangle
it just it just means that i want
everything you know i don't want to have
to press the triangle again
you tag him all right bag him and tag
him
oh is there another one oh no i bit that
oh i got smacked
okay is that everyone
yeah i also don't care how people
play on the highest difficulty the first
time they play a game
but more power to you if you do
right
um
yeah i wish dynamic dreamer i also wish
they added the feature from last of us
where you just walk over stuff and you
pick it up
especially in a game where you
craft a bunch of stuff you know
yeah there you go
launching you don't really use a lot in
this game even though you can
like launch off grapple points and then
apparently just fall off um
i barely ever use it
but maybe that's just me
you almost start the game on the highest
difficulty it's more immersive wow
see i would be afraid that i would get i
mean it's less an issue with modern
games where you can change the
difficulty but like i would be afraid
that i would just like work myself into
a corner and get stuck and then get
frustrated and then drop it
well that sounds good
all right
[Music]
machines killing osram and leaving acid
everywhere
great
easy
that was close
does this game support gyroscopic aiming
you know what i saw a video go around
yesterday let's see um let's see
uh
i assume it's in controls
motion aiming
okay
uh one sec
um okay we'll give it a go we'll give it
a go uh it does support hdr um i have
hdr turned off because um i'm streaming
and just my um
i don't know it just probably wouldn't
look as nice
let's see what the gyroscope
oh okay so this is me using the
gyroscope
i
i don't know if i like it personally
but also you can still use the up and
down of the actual controller i think
that would maybe need some fine tuning
to make it a little bit more comfortable
for me to use but you can use it
so massive g thank you for uh that
question because now i know that that is
a proper option
um
there any lats up here i don't think so
nearby
if i can release the clamps the shuttle
should fall right into the waist
oh there is a boy
let's see let's see
okay so we got this guy
[Music]
that guy
[Music]
this guy
i think that's everyone
is he just over there
okay
can i make any
no shoot okay
it's making you dizzy
with the gyroscope
honestly my favorite part of the game
has been like i really enjoy the loop
especially when you get to the west and
like
it's a little bit of you know making
people work together
um going out i just really enjoy
uncovering like the big climbing puzzles
like they they are easily my favorite
part of the game um because it reminds
me of like
assassin's creed 2
um
which is
one of my personal favorite games but
they always did that really cool thing
where you had like
really cool climbing puzzle um
and i think you definitely lost that
with like later assassin's creed games
where you could climb on literally
anything and there wasn't you know
any real thought behind it you know
and so it's uh horizon west has a lot of
those too which i really enjoy in like
tallnecks aren't just like oh i found
tallneck i'm gonna climb it there's
loads of you have to each one is like
its own nice little challenge
um
and i think that is makes a lot of fun
where are you going
did i unhighlight you then
yeah it's kind of a weird one because
like
part of me wishes that aloy sort of
didn't have a focus i get that that's
the thing that makes us special
um
but you i i definitely find myself over
relying on it
um
which
is a bit of a shame you know
let's just beat up this lad like
normally
shot him in the butt okay
i played on resolution mode so i was
playing in 30 um on my first playthrough
which i mean looks gorgeous um
it looks gorgeous in performance mode
too um
but i just i really wanted to you know
play it in that 4k
sweet sweet 4k
speaking of tallneck lucy getting that
lego set don't tempt me i really like
the fact that there's a lego set
the shadows caught up in those cables
i'm gonna have to climb the tower to
find a way to disconnect them
okay
oh give me some of that
um
focus could help here
yeah the focus is very much elo's
personality i drop the access lift
oh i'm i think i have to turn the
gyroscope off
sorry i'm gonna have to turn the
gyroscope off
i keep forgetting it's there
and then i have it turned on
uh but it's very cool if you want it um
motion aiming
off
it's just not for me
uh there was a thing over here here we
go
how long's the story depending on how
much you put into it
um
tag target
uh
i say you could get it done in like 25
30 hours probably closer to 30. there's
a lot of side stuff and you don't want
to be under leveled for like the final
boss
can you customize the focus color i
don't think you can you can get like
face paint and stuff later on
um and obviously different costumes um
and dies but i don't think you can
change the focus color unless you can do
it in
[Music]
a part of the game that i just didn't
get to
okay
or just like not get to but like just
didn't uncover my playthrough
should be the right spot
there
that connector's holding the cables
together
it should break if i shoot
one
just need to down higher
and attach the second set of cables
scaling an ancient rickety tower with
killer machines waiting down below
okay
is there new game plus at launch no you
have i think you have to beat it
i think i think
i can't remember this new game plus
but you i mean regardless you have to
beat the game
to even find that
um if it is there i'm not sure
[Music]
am i going this way
[Music]
up here again yeah
oh there's a supply chest and i need all
the stuff i can get
yeah it's built it has like little
moments that are very reminiscent of
uncharted she doesn't do like a whoa
whoa whoa but stuff definitely breaks
off as you climb it there's the other
connector
30 hours let's do on stream today wait
it's february i've got stuff to do
um
yes
i need to take this thing down to get to
the center all right
boss fight is it okay
okay where's that weak spot
and he's got a lot of sparks
i should target it first
all right
[Music]
yes
i know
oh
[Music]
there we go
so i can do that please
wow okay
where am i
oh edward you have to you have to cycle
through potions and traps and stuff it's
probably a little bit of a bug bear for
me as well
um
i wish you didn't have to i wish they
like they all had their own wheel but
they don't
yo
i gotta take this thing down
this one
yeah all right
i'm not gonna lie picking up weapons and
then using them against enemies is very
fun
did he drop another one
i've got no ammo
i could just do that all right
there we go
instead
finally
all right let's do some leveling up
um
so we looked like we looked a little bit
um at these skill trees earlier is
anyone
anyone got any um
particular trees that you want to invest
in
so we've got warrior so i mean we only
have
like one skill point so we can get like
a resonator oh let's wait progressive
story to unlock we don't even get that
one all right
uh quick trapper
concentration
only about an hour and 20 in very early
uh concentration boost is pretty good
potent medicine
silent strike um
oh
mounted defense
you can pick up um
sort of like little monster huntery
people there are people who like cook
for you
um or you can like find them in
settlements and you can pick it up
concentration yeah i agree
let's do that
lovely
all right
um
let's go
one sec
yeah so we've got hunter
let me
go center should be straight ahead what
have you got for me obviously i have to
find another way there
[Music]
well
luckily how is uh riding the mountain
this one it's pretty good i would
definitely recommend turning off like
the pathfinding
um
because they love to just sort of
run into trees and things because
they're trying to get back on the road
so i would turn that off
and yeah it's hard to go wrong with
bullet time i should find the server
roll
okay where are we going
i'm close
i have to be
in terms of how the game is i i'm
enjoying it way more than the first one
um
but like it still has some issues for me
like aloy talking to myself all the time
[Music]
it's here
gaia version 6.9
initializing
hello
hi
hey
travis state now what's this we got here
a pharmaceutical conspiracy to steal a
copy of gaia and your subordinate
functions
you want me to handle this liz
blasphemers brew the vipers with a
mighty head that smile and pour troubles
upon you
this ain't no copy a guy you stole your
losers
but it's the mother of all logic bombs
so good luck repairing your data
and next time you start thinking you can
outsmart a tape remember my salute
aloy
the goddess
there is no goddess
i told you that already
that's not gaia
that's not what i'm looking for
it's nothing but a fake
uh
i got it
i'm sorry you have a sharp bite
sometimes you know
but it was pretty amazing to see you fly
off that tower and blow up the entire
basin
the thing is um
there's going to be more of that
i'm out of leads
fall
but i i have to keep searching
and fast and whatever risks i have to
take i will and it doesn't make sense to
have someone with me
someone who might get hurt
this is on me farl
nobody else
hold on
before in meridian you said there was a
man who helped you
silence
you said you used to talk to him a lot
about things you discovered from the old
world things no one else understands and
he gave you the lands you used to defeat
hades he's gone farley i haven't heard
from him since the battle against hades
sure but spymaster murad back in
meridian he's good at finding people
isn't he
come on it might work
plus you'll get to see some friendly
faces again
okay
i
i guess it's worth a shot
we've got a long walk ahead
actually
i've got a better idea
by the sun it's true
she's come back
bless us
the savior of meridian has returned
you earned this welcome
you saved them
not yet
in the name of the sun king of vard a
royal welcome for the champion
make way
murad
alloy has an urgent matter to discuss
da'sheen
that makes two of us
i've sent forth hunters for weeks
the sun fall all the way to the sacred
land searching for you
something happened at the spire
i'll show you
what's your step
you saved us all to be sure but uh
we're still cleaning up the mess
it happened right after the solstice
we were able to explain it away thank
the sun otherwise it might have caused a
panic
one night for less than half a minute it
glowed in angry red
from meridian it looked like a trick of
the light but those who were closer atop
the allied said it could not have been a
reflection
much to my dismay they said the light
rose up from the tower's base
from that
we left everything just as it was
what do you think happened i don't know
the spire supposed to send out signals
messages the terraforming system
but hades tried to use it to wake up
ancient war machines
wait here while i check it out
let us know what you find
all right big
big old uh exposition dump there so
look at the statue
of me
that's
new
i think it looks nice uh so it with
regards to like end of the game
it doesn't seem to be a new game plus
just yet um but the elements but the
story just like
doesn't set you back to a save state
it's just like it puts you in the world
and you can you can finish any side
quests and stuff there
um i know a couple people were asking
about that earlier
i've got a bad feeling about
this thing
transmission
no he wouldn't
he couldn't
something was transmitted from the top
of the spire
i guess i have to find a way up there
um also sorry my
obs has kind of just died a little bit
so hopefully it'll be back on track in a
second
i'll turn the game audio up just a
little bit it should be a little bit of
buffering i don't know if it's
coming back let me know
um
[Music]
ali we're playing on the uh performance
mode so this is like the 60 frames
version
um
okay here we go there we go the stream
should be back now sorry about that i
have comcast internet
and it's not the best um climb up to the
base of the spire
um all right
hades did it exactly
i was gonna say if you've ever watched
my streams before you'll know that i
have uh
i don't know comcast in the bay area has
been uh
not great for the past few months and uh
i constantly get like uh little desyncs
and whatever
it should be good now obs says the board
is green
okay i remember this bit
there we go
should be um this should be 60 frames
it looks like he tricked me
um so actually it's not far after this
little bit um that we get to kind of
explore the open world so make sure to
do that after this little story bit
figure out where he sent it i can track
him down
don't you believe the transition out of
the top will tell me that
doesn't look like i can keep climbing
this way
one thing you'll definitely notice is
that you'll be doing something and then
a lawyer will comment on it telling you
to do something
as you're already doing it
an elevator
let's see
whole thing is opening up
i wonder what the carja will make of
this
[Music]
there's
[Music]
i see you finally figured it out
to be honest i'm surprised it took you
so long to discover my rules
you raked the lance to steal hades
how could you be so reckless reckless
you're the one who tried to purge hades
before its precious knowledge could be
extracted
the mysterious signal that walked for
example
avoid obtaining one of those
you've been having such a hard time
funding
if you knew why didn't you just tell me
i've been having problems of my own
these past six months
the difference is
i've made progress
so once you're angered my entirely
necessary deception has faded
now why don't you come out here and find
me in the forbidden west
and to learn all that i've discovered
oh i'll confirm it
yes
well
then according to make it simple enough
even for you
it's another choice
[Music]
[Music]
it and it transformed
almost like the day of the battle i can
only be grateful that it's a stormy day
if you will of seeing the tower change
from meridian
what did you discover
hades
the danger didn't end here it went into
the forbidden west
and i have to follow i see
that can be difficult
the west is called forbidden for a
reason
try the ferocious warriors controls much
of it it's an act and they allow no
trespassers past its border
that said
under the sun king of art a fragile
piece has been negotiated and indeed the
next embassy will take place in a day or
two on the edge of the frontier
where you two attend the gathering under
his auspices
the tanakh might grant right of passage
instead of hunting you
and attacking on sight
just what i need
more killers
the sun came
eloy
it's good to see you
you left in such haste we never had a
chance to properly thank you can we show
the champion the spear now please eat
them in quiet
it's true we bear gifts
decorum usually calls for a ceremony of
offering at the palace
but i thought you would prefer a less
formal occasion
bring them please avad this is all very
kind but i
move it vanessa
quick better hand them over before she
runs off again
really
must you
try it on
that's beautiful on behalf of all the
citizens of the sundance
may these tokens remind you of our
eternal gratitude
perhaps you'd like to spend more time
with your friends
come speak to me when you're ready to
depart
all right
i need to so master override to my new
speaker finally at the point in the game
where we're just about to get
outside
in the sunshine uh so let's
let's modify the spear
and then
chat to people and then get out and uh
check out the open world but it's not
even we're not even getting to the
forbidden west yet though that takes a
little bit
uh where is the
bench is it up there
how much of the game is stealth honestly
not i don't think i've come across like
a stealth section
um
like a forced stealth section at least
like most i just play stealthily um
master override installed
plus something new
to store up and release energy
uh
resonator should help in a fight
so yeah when you ask how much of the
game is stealth
genuinely
however much you want to put into it i
haven't had a full stealth section
um
but i just prefer to play a bit stealthy
because i think some of the best
abilities in the game are more stealth
oriented
are you ready to go
or do you need a little more time
let's just go
i better get going
and if i'm headed west it sounds like
i'll need right of passage from the
tanakh as you said
where exactly is this embassy going to
be held
past the dance the canyon that marks the
western border of the sundance you'll
find the fortress of barren light at its
farthest edge
the embassy will take place just beyond
its gates
it's a long march
fortnight on foot
a couple of days hard riding should get
us there
actually it might be better to rest here
tonight
head out in the morning of course
i'll arrange it
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
am i the one to hold
this crown of ash and salt their kind
[Music]
these words don't seem like mine
[Music]
no matter what i try
[Music]
emptiness
in the storm
[Music]
the wave inside my soul
carries on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
to find the path we lost
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
who can take my hand
in
[Music]
sparks to steal
never seen anyone use one of those to
get around
is that how i get to baron light uh yes
i mean usually but not today not yet
and why is that
well the daunt
the whole valley
it's infested with machines
i can handle machines oh i'm sure you
can but
i'm under strict orders not to operate
until the whistle down at chain scrape
sounds the all clear
look
i didn't come all this way just to stand
around and wait
i'll crank that car down myself if i
have to
well but then
who would crank it back up
fine fine
though
should anyone ask
it might be best to say you forced me
i see smoke but not a lot of activity
smoke's probably coming from something
the machine's wrecked
as for the quiet well
there's a work stoppage in effect
because of
all the fuss
what sort of machines are causing the
trouble
nasty ones and lots of them
bristlebacks they're called
strangeness is they're not native to the
dot just showed up
all of a sudden no hunters to kill them
oh we've got hunters just none that want
to cross alvin
boss of chain scrape
he is self-appointed work stopped which
was his idea
yeah well i'm just
passing through
got an embassy to attend
you should have said that ain't gonna
happen no time
soon are you talking about
hear that that's your answer
who is that karja's son priest cranked
him down yesterday about an hour before
the machine trouble started
he's a very important man
he says
that embassy at baron light he is the
one supposed to run it
great
if you don't do as i say immediately the
sun king himself shall hear of your
insolence
thanks to you i was forced to spend the
night shivering in the tent exposed to
attack i might have died
oh me you refused to transport but not
this
this
what
this nora girl
this savage besides scallywag
juarez
that's a-loi studious juardis
aloy you know savior of meridian
really
well
that lesson's the insult i suppose
i came here for the embassy at baronite
way i hear it so did you well
not with the valley infested
and so did aramon
proclaim the sun priests
most precious
and worthy of safe keeping see
scripture
i shall head to barren light
when the captain of the vanguard tells
me the way is clear
and not a moment sooner
fine
captain's a friend of mine you know
where is aaron
wouldn't mind speaking to someone a
little more action a little less
scroll
juarez studious wadis
studious wadi sent aaron and another
vanguard out of daybreak to clear the
way and so
hey
down the valley then
yeah said they checked the ruins on the
left bank for tracks take it from there
okay
i here there's a work stoppage any way
to upgrade my gear i'll bet the smith
chain scrape would let you use his
workbench
as for the bristlebacks you might want
to craft some acid arrows
hitting their canisters with those will
take them down quick
thanks
i'll find aaron and i'll bring
hey
where do you think you're going what to
the top of the ridge to wait in safety
sorry
operators under strict orders
no passengers for the whistle blows
right that's right
best start cranking
why
why
jorah would you kindly escort studious
to chain scrape and wait for me there
you got
it i will find aaron and i will help
clear a path
but after that
no more excuses
baron light
embassy
if such be the will of the sun
it will be
trust me
all right we're finally out into the
open so people have been asking like
what how big the map is also jesus it
feels like i've been quiet for such a
long time uh there's obviously quite a
lot of uh story
and whatever to get through but we're
finally kind of out a little bit um
let's take a look at the map so
it kind of plunks you down around here
uh
and then
let's
just
oh
yeah
pretty uh
pretty big map
um
as you can tell
uh and so yeah that's just like a little
bit of it obviously the fact that you
can um you can fast travel so there's
like annoying things with the first
travel it's like if you are at a
campfire you can travel for free to
another campfire but if you're not at a
campfire you have to use like a pack
um in order to do that
i think in terms of how it lays out the
map it
i think it does a good job of populating
it without being too overwhelming um
and you know there's a lot of things
like
little uh cities um
like chain scrape i'll take you to
change because i think that place is
genuinely fun we'll try and do like a
rebel outpost as well because i am i
actually really enjoyed doing those they
remind me a lot of like
doing assassin's creed um
far cry outposts
so let's let's head down so where are we
going where we going
campfire there and then we'll just
follow it's to number one all right
fast travel i think this is the first
point where fast travel works so like as
you see fast travel free
i can't go anywhere right now i can
maybe go here no because i haven't
unlocked that campfire see i can't
travel the r2 is uh
not is-is greyed out or
i don't i have a pack here so if i go to
my map
i could fast travel somewhere because i
have like one of those little camping
packs
i just showed the full map but here you
go again this is the furthest out that i
can zoom
uh it's pretty big
pretty big
um and obviously you kind of unlock the
map you kind of remove the
uh fog of war by traveling through it or
um
by uh by
unlocking the tallnecks and that kind of
clears a lot of the map for you what's
up here that's unknown let's take a look
oh
so it's like some kind of
tower
can i climb it
that's the eternal question can i climb
it
playing on a ps5 jerry
i'm playing in the uh 60 frames
performance mode right now i'm careful
not to let this stain my hands
can i go this way no i'll be
okay
i don't think i can get past them so
this is something that you unlock like
later on in the game there's a few of
these you can't necessarily get
everywhere straight away
you have to unlock a specific
thing so there's one um
there's like this other one which kind
of looks like a bit of a red
um
like a red gem thing
that you um you unlock pretty early on
you can explode those which is pretty
cool unlocks more paths for you
um
i was about to jump off there but i
don't have my shield wings that could
have been a disaster um
but yeah it does a pretty good job of
like kind of gating off some stuff
so you're not kind of
exploring everything
at the very beginning drew said i could
get my blood you can pick up items while
you're riding on a machine but your your
machine will stop um it doesn't just
like run over them and pick it up
um compass can be turned off yep all the
hud can be turned off and fiddled around
with um i have it on dynamic right now
so like the um
so here because my objective has changed
it's appeared um but it doesn't stay on
the screen the whole time if i swipe up
on the directional pad the whole hud
comes up
um like that
welcome to chainscrape xavier
open up guys dwarves
forged
petra so pick up a couple of side
missions in here
um
just because it's like i think they're a
little bit more interesting a little
more fleshed out nice to see you too but
then we'll then we'll take we'll go
explore
come on
i
damn brewery is the only thing i can
count on in this place
yeah i heard
machines work stoppage oh those are just
the latest malfunctions chainscrape's
always been a few tools short of a kit
and right there is the biggest tool of
all our land not our problem the
bristlebacks are everybody roland
you've heard of him
yeah
but he's a story best told over a cold
beer
uh petra petra
i'm just passing through
i'm headed west
oh
there's an embassy at baron light i need
to make happen and then i
keep moving
ah
of course
bigger gears to grind
well flame hair
good to see you
you've got to move on
petra
but if you want a cold beer and a few
laughs with an old friend come find me
at the brewery your choice
well this old one guy sounds like
trouble
maybe petra could use some support
but first things first i need to find
that workbench and upgrade my bow
let's get some upgrades going and then
we'll head out into
the wilds
oh wait no i can use it i can't use the
bench i remember some of these folks um
you can't use some of the um
uh merchants at the very beginning of
the game because there's like some stuff
going on there's some stuff going on all
right
[Music]
oh we got some acid hunter oh i can
upgrade it to two
can we go all the way can we go to three
no i need to borrow a sound shell all
right but
um you can also upgrade the
armor so you get like extra skills like
more concentration regen more potent
medicine here and you unlock weaves too
so it's great it's like it's super
useful the one thing i would say is that
you obviously like
get a like if you go to merchants you
get a ton of options and a ton of stuff
to choose from so i wouldn't necessarily
like waste resources upgrading stuff at
the very beginning
um i focus typically i would say if
you're gonna upgrade anything
upgrade all this like resource pouches
like look how many more berries you can
carry
um carry more bombs carry more arrows um
carry more traps and potions it's super
super useful i definitely
recommend up doing all these but like
these are all um
you have to hunt organics to do this
which is actually way more in line with
like if you remember how far cry 3 did
it like you'd have to go around the
island and kill animals and use their
hides and similar similarly here like
using a squirrel bone or using a scroll
hide one thing i really like to do is so
for example if i want to upgrade my
quiver um create a job
and it'll point out where raccoons are
going to be in the
environment for you
see there's a bunch of raccoons down
here um
which is very nice so
let's
grab
i should be able to grab a charger so
let's go and see if i can do i have one
like that overridden already no i don't
know
okay this should be useful
let's go see i just need to find aaron
and help him where the charges are at
[Music]
is this on the psp
no it's not playing on playstation 5
um
which i should they should have like
yeah here we go so trophy tracking
in here now
doesn't seem to be like
um
real activity details like it's not i i
guess it doesn't it's not really
it doesn't necessarily it has the
activity cards but it doesn't have the
sort of ps plus walk through stuff
unless it's because my ps plus is
expired on this account
which is very possible back
maybe errand took it down
no idea about a pc release if it's even
coming to pc or when
i think it's not outside of the realm of
possibility playstation has been putting
a lot of their first party stuff on pc
um the original horizon came to pc but i
don't think it's going to be
anytime soon because they obviously want
people to play it on console which has
the uh you know they'll probably get
more money from that
because people have to buy a playstation
console to play oh hello sir
i'm sorry
but you are useful to me um
[Music]
how do i get to
okay the charge is around the corner
dualsense implementation is very good
um you kind of get when you when you're
using a bow you obviously get that kind
of tension in it
um
how do i get around there okay
you get the tension in the bow um which
feels really good like i'm really
impressed with it it's um not something
that i would typically like
really enjoy
uh i think it's implemented very very
well um i think also the fact that they
use the um like the speaker to great
effect
um it feels good i i enjoy what they've
done with the dual sense integration
oh yeah if we're talking about pc
releases for any places games when's
bloodborne coming
people have been asking for that for so
long
just give us a bloodborne on pc
okay
can i override these boys that's a
question if i've come all this way to
override one
oh how do i get down there i can repel
from over there
i really want like tam is reading
berserk at the moment um obviously
there's a lot of formsoft
looks like
fans of uh from software miyazaki in
particular of berserk and it feeds into
the stuff like bloodborne
and dark souls a lot so i do kind of i
do want to read it
but i don't know if i want to read it
because i know it'll never end because
the uh the person who made it sadly died
okay
so
i hope i can i just rode one of these so
i assume
oh no no
no you idiot
trying to get a charger to go over there
come on
there we go
have i noticed anything with the 3d
audio
um
honestly i have i've been playing mostly
like
through speakers which is not obviously
the best way to use 3d audio um at all
um
but i do think the audio is pretty good
is eloise single
yeah
she's got bigger fish to fry
come on
all right let's go
let's just go out
let me get the charger and nose right is
because i don't
think
you have to do the cauldrons again to
unlock
different um
like different mounts to ride and so at
the beginning you can ride charges very
easily but like
later on you need other mounts um
am i going the right way yes i am
yeah i would say that they're still not
the easiest to control like this boy is
uh
[Music]
really trying
to like
beer off the road which isn't
necessarily the most helpful
i'm playing in the performance mode
so this is the 60 frames i'm streaming
hopefully it's 60.
at least that's what my obs is telling
me i am
yeah ellie can't whistle anymore um
you throw rocks instead which kind of
sucks
um because i really enjoyed whistling
but i get why they would want
people to not abuse that and like just
overly you know use it
can you ride something that flies
you watch the trailers they do show a
very very cool mount
and that's all i'll say on that make it
worth your while
because
playstation themselves spoiled it
i don't want to be responsible for that
writing writing does feel good on the
jewel sense like they do have really
cool um like the the haptic feedback on
it is really great
um
so here we go we're in the oh new relic
ruin the daunt
but yeah like i would say controlling is
not
controlling controlling these boys is
not exactly the the high point i would
say
so baron lights down there i don't know
if i can go beyond baron light honestly
until i progress
to a bit in the story
oh i don't feel good about that
um i certainly killed that boy
i personally prefer fidelity
which plays in 30 but it like
60 for me sometimes can feel a little
bit too snappy a little bit too quick um
so i kind of prefer the the sort of not
sluggish but like the kind of more
measured approach that i feel like it
plays out when you play in the other
mode
um
i'm just gonna jump come on
look
yeah so yeah ayla can like properly swim
um
there's bits later on where you kind of
get like a diving mask
um which is pretty cool i think this is
the first i can go at this point
and i don't know
what else is necessarily like around
here to check out i don't think there's
another
like for example there's not any kind of
rebel
rebel camp um around
there's an unknown thing there but i
might not be able to get in because i
don't have the thing
um
but no let me know what you want to see
let me know what you want to see because
we could just go to chain scrape
um let me grab a let me grab this
campfire
look at the water all right
yeah what looks good
swimming i will say is like it's still
not my favorite
um
you know i just think that's
par for the course with
most games though i think it's very
difficult to do a kind of fun
swimming
so this is this is in the 60 frames mode
i'll change it back to the other mode in
a sec
to see
if there is that big difference
let me grab some of this
i don't know why i'm getting machine
kill assists maybe my mount is doing
some work
um
let's go back to visuals and yeah now a
favor and resolution
is this elder circle
i can't wait for a whole thing
all right
this is
hmm
yeah so i mean the problem is is that
like i could boot up my save i have like
a file that's halfway through
the game but
obviously i don't want to boot it up in
case i accidentally spoil something uh
because that would be a really chromy
thing to do like ahead of release so i
don't want to be doing all that sorry
hunter hunting grounds are closed until
the bristles
um
all right let's go to chain scrape very
quickly and then
where is chain screw that's baron light
chain scrapes over here where's my
latest uh i don't really have a close
enough that'll do
does it have ray tracing
i don't
know also jesus i forget how quickly it
loads
let's go back let's go
james creep
oh i can't know i can travel there okay
yeah late game streams are still under
embargo um
because obviously that would suck like
imagine just spoiling the whole game but
also there's some key plot points that
like don't want to spoil um
which are
genuinely really cool and i would hate
to have them spoiled for me so i
don't want to be doing all that let's go
talk to this chef boy
yeah the ssd is very impressive and like
the load the load screens in this are
just non-existent
well they're existing but you know
they're very quick hey milda
bilda
i took some of your stew last time i
went into the wild
kept me going for a week
felt like i could have put a strider in
a sleeper hole
enjoy it while it lasts
sounds like you're serving up some uh
impressive provisions here
not again
you can have the discount too but you'll
have to come back later i think you have
me confused with someone else oven
didn't send you
no
oh
my apologies
it's just that his minions won't stop
pestering me
now i've even worn out my special grill
since i'm in the midst of a crisis
perhaps you could skip to what it is you
wanted some of your
food
of course
your last customer mentioned your
cooking really kept him going out in the
wild
where i'm headed i could use some of
that
i would be happy to oblige it especially
since you have the decency to ask
pleasantly
but but my special groove griddle is no
more
without it i can't cook any of my
signature dishes
i hate to think what will happen when
i'm forced to refuse alvin or his goons
even if i already had the right
ingredients there's nothing i can do
unless
you can source me a temporary
replacement
what do you need
for the ingredients
a few pieces of decent wild meat and i'd
say a big handful of bitter leaf stems
that'll do as for the griddle a
corrugated metal panel might suffice
until i can have a new one forged you'd
likely find one in the scrounger pile if
you follow the river to the northeast
don't worry i'll clean it first you'll
have no issue finding boars and bitter
leaf on your way
assuming you're as much a
hunter-gatherer as your clothing
suggests thanks milduff i'll keep an eye
out
so that's what gratitude sounds like and
don't let anyone push you around okay
if you say so
a dash of courage
yeah
so i mean it is obviously fetch quests
um so let's do this one and then we'll
probably call it but it's like it
already feels much more i don't know
it's less oh i really need this it's
giving you a character who actually has
like a decent motivation and backstory
so i really i'm appreciating the side
missions a lot more
um
this time around because in the in the
first in the first game i just blasted
through the main story none of the side
stuff really
interested me um so we got scroungers
and then was this the one that was
closest yeah okay let's go grab some of
this
bitter leaf how many do we need
i was gonna say if you're gonna if
you're gonna ask anyone
to get you some ingredients better make
it the savior of meridian right
okay i think i have
okay then what do we need from over here
wild meat
five wild meat all right
let's tag this boy
i mean the thing is as well though this
is the very beginning of the game
like this is
the tiniest bit of the map
we haven't actually even got to the
forbidden west like it takes you a
couple hours at least to get there um
so this this part like very much feels
like og horizon
but like if you like the original
horizon i would recommend it i even
didn't particularly enjoy the original
horizon and i'm enjoying this one a
whole lot more i think the gameplay loop
is a lot more fun
get back here oh come on
i don't feel good about killing all
these pigs though
um
oh okay i needed that boy
four out of five we need one more
oh i feel bad hunting reckons
they're really cute
there we go
okay
there that should be enough wild meat
for milduff
will you be my valentine bit late
what do i need
a bit late i'm afraid
i already had one
my god son was my valentine
and also my boyfriend
what did robot dinosaurs eat anyway
that's a good point it's a question that
i've never actually worried
that's a question i've never even really
thought of
okay scrounges
scroungers
i would have said i could find a metal
penny in one of their scrap piles
i'll have to find a cauldron out here to
learn how to override that
okay
why did that strike from above instead
of uh
[Music]
[Music]
what
wow
okay
i got absolutely smack there
all right let's stealth this a little
bit
more said i could find a metal panel in
one of their scrap pies
is that a scrap pile
yeah all right
no
come
i'm waiting for that one to turn away
here we go
stop it
one thing i'll say is it when stuff goes
wrong
it gets
it gets dicey very quickly
and i'm playing off like my muscle
memory of a
like
completed
or like
you know end game save
where i have all these different weapons
and stuff and now i'm like oh yeah i
don't have the ability that makes me go
invisible
which i maybe overuse in the main game
oh
wow did that not get you
okay there we go
one thing i will say is that i never
really use melee combat
did i hit the tree yeah i think i did
okay
pile
so i've been through that one
been through that one
there we go
a sling bomb still a pete yeah i would
say so
traps definitely more so but sling bombs
are still definitely very powerful
all right let's pop back and hand in
this side quest
and make this man believe in himself you
know
hey sarah i'm just gonna run back
good job thank you
do my wrists and hands ever get tired
playing with dual sense honestly yes so
i actually suffer a lot with repetitive
strain injury and so
i didn't do it for this game but um for
this you know stream today but when i
played this for the first time
when i got the game i remapped it
um because clicking in the thumbstick
kind of kills me
a lot um and so i remapped
up on the d-pad to be my focus um
instead of clicking in the thumbstick
um
and yeah it's oh my god
get off
um which helped me a lot honestly um
there's a few great accessibility
features that lets you like completely
remap everything
um
and so if you also struggle definitely
recommend doing that i have also turned
down the vibration on the haptic
feedback on the dual sense because
sometimes it can be a little bit much
um
so yes i'll answer your question
i l someone said earlier the slide looks
crap no the slide is great the slide is
so
so much fun
i'm liking it yeah i've yeah i've been i
enjoyed it way more than i enjoyed the
first one like i finished the first game
but like it didn't i didn't like it as
much as a lot of other people did um but
this one's definitely much better there
you are
i happen to receive another visit from
oven himself
he was pushy but i stood my ground and
dare i say it i even got my own back yes
i did
i'm listening
when i made his meal
i used three pinches of salt
instead of two
each journey begins with a single step i
guess
i think i have everything you asked for
then just as you have inspired me let us
see if i can return the favor time to
cook
wow mild if that was
inspired
next time you want the best provisions
you know where to find me
your next order of any dish will be on
the house
thanks
and don't forget to stand up for
yourself funny you should say that
as it happens i'm already cooking up my
next portion of resistance
hope to see you again
hey we did it um so yeah those are just
like they're called errands which is
funny because i'm meant to be meeting
errands from the first game right now
but you get kind of like
quests side quests um so you've got like
the active ones um you've got your main
quests
errands which are just like usually the
um the old collectible things
you've got jobs that was what i did
earlier when i went to the um
workbench and i was like here i'm gonna
upgrade i'm gonna upgrade my hunter
arrow quiver this is the job i need to
do to do it then you've got things like
tallnecks relic ruins uh hunting grounds
like there's tons of side content but
none of it is really like
to the point where it feels super super
overwhelming and like there's too much
to do
here though you know yet food provides
temporary benefits and skill boosts a
little bit like monster huntery i guess
um
some the the food that i just got from
that guy that i helped out um reduces my
concentration recovery time which is
great um and you can only really have
one move one food effect at a time
though so you can't like stack them but
still useful nonetheless
um i'm gonna call it there for today
just the first couple two and a half
hours of the game
thank you so much everyone who's been
watching and asking questions
um we have a ton more horizon content
going on um i worked on a little like
tips video um which will help you kind
of with like early game tips that's live
right now max worked on a combat
guide uh max is like an incredible like
he
just strings the stuff together and
explains it in a way that helps you
really improve your combat that's why
i've been sliding so much is because max
was like yo this is really powerful you
should definitely use it um
so definitely recommend looking up that
phil and mark on the editorial side have
been putting in a ton of work um doing
guides and
that's all going to be on gamespot.com
if you want those written versions we
also have the um
the video review and the written review
which you want to check out if you want
to see more in depth but hopefully i
could give you a little look at the
beginning of the game um thank you
everyone for watching and i'll catch you
next time bye